[Music]
we were totally devastated when we found
out the Fosters was ending after five
awesome years but then freeform gave us
the gift of a sequel good trouble is
going to be an amazing show so stay
tuned to find out who will be making a
cameo do you love watching all the best
TV shows and movies is venge watch your
middle name be sure to subscribe to keep
up with all the four one one about your
favorite shows and movies it's all about
Callie and Mariana good trouble will
follow the lives of adoptive sisters
Callie and Mariana Foster we couldn't be
more excited to find out where their
lives take them these two sisters and
besties are going to take the world by
storm in this new show in the Fosters
Mariana is the super smart one who
struggles a lot with finding herself she
is also hey-zeus is twin sister she's
got a gift for math and coding which
will totally feature in the new spit off
she's super girly and social and a
natural leader we can't wait to see how
this translates into her adult life
Callie joined the family at the
beginning of the original series she was
a super trouble teen because she
experienced some crazy tragic stuff
early in her life she had to save the
life of her little brother from their
stepdad at a young age and gets sent to
juvie but she soon thrives with the
Fosters who loved her despite all her
issues she really learned how to be an
awesome person once she had the support
of a great family she grows into an
independent strong woman we can't wait
to see where life takes her in good
trouble its sat in the future the
Fosters was on TV for five years but
five years did not pass on the TV show
time ran much slower on the show so we
mostly see the foster kids in high
school but the news show doesn't just
pick up after Callie and Brandon's
graduation though good trouble takes
place several years later the show
starts with Callie having graduated from
both college and law school she gets a
job with a conservative judge and she's
going to find herself fighting against
the system a lot Callie is going to make
a great attorney it's totally the
perfect job for her don't you think we
hope she ends up
using her degree to help other kids like
herself Mariana everyone's favorite Cody
nerd it's a job in the tech world she
has to learn how to navigate a very
male-dominated world if we just know
she'll have lots to say about that
the girl is moving to an apartment in
Los Angeles and it's all about them
making greatness out of their lives we
know they will but it's called good
trouble so that greatness probably won't
come easy it's going to be great seeing
how Callie and Mariana navigate
adulthood at least they have each other
oh my god I can't believe we just bought
a car new characters as Callie and
Mariana and bark on their new lives
together they are going to meet a ton of
new people we are so pumped about all
the new characters that will be on the
good trouble there's Gale who's been
described as a socially conscious
graphic designer
he's pretty politically active he lives
in the same apartment complex as Callie
and Mariana Finn there's Malika we don't
know too much about how she meets Callie
and Mariana yaks but Malika is a super
smart lady
and she's also a former foster kid it
sounds like she will have a lot in
common with Mariana and Callie
davia is a teacher who also lives in the
same apartment complex and alice is the
manager of the apartments Callie works
for a judge named judge Wilson he's
super conservative and Callie is super
not we know that will cause major
clashes there's also Benjamin who works
with Callie but he's not liberal like
she is Callie is going to have a rough
time in the working world all these
young people living in the apartment
complex have diverse backgrounds and are
trying to live their best lives the show
creators are definitely trying to appeal
to that millennial crowd to release when
the last episode of the Fosters aired on
March 13 2018 we were absolutely
devastated the episode was just so sad
but it really showed how families
overcome hard times and that's really
what the Fosters was all about it was a
great final episode even if we did go
through about three boxes of tissues we
were so glad to find out that we don't
have to give up our favorite TV family
so when does the new show
premiere good trouble airs in January
2019 the show's creators really wasted
no time in continuing this story it's
almost like we're just getting another
season of the Fosters but we're so
excited about the fresh new take of good
trouble we just can't wait for it to
come out
hurry up January at least for now we
have time to binge watch all five
seasons of the Fosters again we'll grab
the chocolate if you bring the tissues
we think it's awesome but they are
wasting no time in bringing us a spinoff
this way they won't lose their loyal
fanbase
plus the storylines of the original
series are still fresh in everyone's
mind January 2019 is going to be amazing
the first season we already know that
the new show takes place several years
after the end of the Fosters Mariana and
Callie head out on their own to live
their best lives in Los Angeles
they are totally trying to live that
glam life we know they are going to have
some issues in the workplace as they try
to navigate how they fit into their new
careers but they are also going to find
out just how hard it is to live on your
own after college they're going to get
into a bit of a financial bind rent in
Los Angeles definitely isn't cheap and
learning how to budget and pay bills is
a relatable challenge for everyone who
is that age we can't wait to see how
they overcome that challenge the first
season is going to have 13 episodes yes
that is plenty of drama to fulfill our
love of the foster family we don't know
yet how many seasons there will be the
creators have to see how successful the
first one is but if it's as successful
as the Fosters there's a good chance we
will be seen Callie and Mariana for a
long time the original series ran for
five seasons in a total of 104 episodes
we can only hope we get that many
episodes of good trouble or maybe even
more that would be epic
Noah since neo returns Noah's Antonio
has recently taken the world by storm
and won the hearts of fans all over the
world he has recently starred in the
Netflix rom-com - all the boys I've
loved before and he played pretty much
the perfect boyfriend he's playing
another teen heartthrob in Sierra
Burgess as a loser which premieres on
that
sends up timber 2019 before he was the
handsome and charming Peter Kavinsky on
to all the boys I've loved before he
played hey-zeus adams-foster for three
seasons replacing the previous actor hey
Zeus is the twin brother of Marianna
he's incredibly loyal to her and later
to all of his family he's got some
issues though they had a rough start in
life after their biological mom made
some terrible choices and abandon them
he's also made some really bad decisions
when it came to wrestling but he learned
from them hey Zeus is an awesome
character and we're glad he is returning
he won't be a series regular though
after all
Noah Santino has a lot of work coming up
since he's hollywood's hottest new star
we aren't sure exactly how many episodes
Noah will be in but we know he will be
in at least two it just wouldn't be the
same if he didn't make an appearance at
all keep watching to find out who else
is returning from the original series
behind the scenes the official good
trouble Instagram account is giving us
life we've been following it faithfully
and we're obsessed with all the new
photos coming out on the set there's a
great photo of Noah Centennial and
Mariana and Callie it is totes adorbs
also we get to see the new characters
Gale is played by Tommy Martinez do you
think he'll end up as a love interest
for one of the girls and we're digging
the laid-back vibes with Alice the
apartment manager it looks like good
trouble is going to be an amazing show
for representation and we just love all
the shots of Callie and Mariana unset
check out Mariana looking all fierce and
her behind the scenes seat she really
looks like she's come into her own
Callie is looking super professional in
her sheep lawyer wardrobe her character
has really come a long way she might
have the most character growth of any of
the foster family we can't wait to see
how she continues to thrive also can we
just talk about how cute their apartment
is that set is amazing we wish we could
room with Callie and Mariana lights
camera action the Fosters was an amazing
show not just because of the actors and
the storylines but the episodes were
always directed so perfectly and the new
show is going to have
up with directors leading these new
shows the first episode will be directed
by Jon M Chu he's the guy behind step
off and crazy rich Asians so you know
what the first episode is going to be
perfection Troian Bellisario is also
headed to the director's chair she is
famous for directing some of the best
episodes of Pretty Little Liars she
definitely knows how to get some hot
drama in a TV show she had directing
episode six which is called swipe right
that sounds like there is definitely
going to be some internet dating going
on but even with all these new faces at
the helm we know good trouble will have
the same vibes as the Fosters Johanna
Johnson and Peter page who created the
Fosters are returning as executive
producers there's no doubt that these
two show runners will have picked the
absolute best writers and directors for
the spinoff don't be fooled a private
education is not necessarily a better
one where is the original cast Noah
Centennial our beloved hay-zu's foster
may have become the most successful of
the foster kids and we know he's got an
impressive resume coming up but what are
all the rest of the actors from the
Fosters up to teri polo who played staff
has been busy she has two movies in the
works
foreign exchange comes out sometime in
2018 Sheree some with the actress who
played Lena has just completed work on a
short film called first strike butcher
knife Danny Nucci who played Mike Foster
is continuing his cop persona he's
playing a detective in a couple of
episodes of the rookie Maya Mitchell
isn't just reprising her role as Kalyan
good trouble she is also slated to
appear and Pretty Little Liars the
perfectionists which also debuts in 2019
she'll be amazing in a role like that
it's good to see so many of the actors
from the Fosters are up to great things
we can't wait to see more of them on our
screens okay manual Labor's done I gotta
get home thank you guys for fun night
guess who's back although the new series
focuses on Callie and Marianas new lives
it just wouldn't be right if we didn't
see the rest of the foster family the
show creators have planned on having all
of the family members guest star
various episodes of good trouble so
besides hey Zeus who else will we be
seen in season one well we'll definitely
be seeing the girls moms in the first
half of the show Lena and staff are both
back and they will be making an
appearance as Callie and Mariana get
into a bit of a bind they may be back
for even more we will also get to see
Jude returning for at least two episodes
Callie wanted to stay close to Jude so
we'll get to see them reunited as well
and we'll definitely get to see some
Brandon his character is living in Los
Angeles
he's been confirmed for at least two
episodes we don't know if we'll see the
whole family together at the same time
but hey that's part of growing up right
we absolutely can't wait for good
trouble to premiere in January 2019 if
you need us we'll be re watching the
Fosters from the beginning who are you
most excited to see return in good
trouble let us know in the comments and
that's all we know about the new TV show
good trouble keep up with all the latest
shows by subscribing and check out our
community page for more awesome content
[Music]